let's play another game Dark Passenger
p.m. dark passage on the way let's let's
try this the Duncan subt subtle system
that stuff has Nakamura has played this
a couple of times probably the idea of
playing something that naka is playing s
is bad for me not exactly my style but
ok let's let's see what happens here
yeah why does grabbing lots of space
here could it could be could be me on
the white side I also try to grab space
in the center if possible ok but let's
see how to continue maybe the night to G
form the issue with those palm pushes is
and I have lost my fair share mount of
games in this fashion is some all right
you probably are in good shape but
you're also weakening lots of squares
and your king is often exposed you have
a big space toothpaste advantage and are
really pressing but then it's not so
clear that it's so great actually ok
Neji for I have some I have some squares
that I can use I wonder I wonder I
wonder yeah let's let's do this first
it's not too bad I wondered what Bishop
takes you three probably insane but
tarlochan
and now I wanted to play you five but
I'm not sure that this is really good
you five
I could also just take which isn't too
too bad and even castles and what you
five just you five hmm I don't know okay
that's cancel
24 I probably can play me five that was
my idea at least intending to unroot
when t6 play rock da truck t2 yeah I
don't know okay let's do this cannot
think all day about this yeah he didn't
even consider this in in much detail
probably am correctly I mean not that
I'm criticizing that can you take him
and now I get get squares 95 Queen
attacking this poll yeah let's get rid
of this I really want a night against
bishop here this is one of those cases
where the night is really a good a good
piece okay Queen to e3 instantly yeah
probably my aunt okay and i always have
925 now i need to make sure that he
cannot miss them and maybe looking it
was more precise i cannot play looking
for anyway
yeah this is nice the night is a good
PCM rook c8 I cannot play but it's not a
big deal I can play a fire freezing
freezing the King side and then I try to
play for minority attack rook c8 and so
on sxb five like here proves a bit and
let's see if I managed to play a 6b five
or b-five instantly was also be nice
with Roxy to wear something ok let's
let's first double up here maybe the
evil I can do some some maneuvering
doesn't really hurt
if I get an end game with night against
bishop this also could be nice but it
depends on the concrete position okay if
I know when ship it back a five
and then here he cannot play c5 I think
oops he did I think at the end i have
got rock a to wear this is a really a
problem yes I did night it's almost a
meat isn't this this bad for you Knight
f3 from Bishop g2 on IG for come on and
this must be good now for black
it's how exactly night here Bishop g2 I
don't see it nergy for Bishop g2
hmm Jesus must be something I didn't I
didn't see it check check
check
hi morning check yeah okay I've got 18
seconds so now show me how I win here
the compare are not such an easy win
maybe maybe here when I started to give
the checks here this position isn't that
when I can't believe this yeah 94 ah
okay three yeah okay three is actually
good f4 it's a good move okay three
threatening f4 hmm he wants to plate
this it wants to play this and now
getting to g6 but I'm not sure that this
is really a win I mean it's it's nice if
it is it winning not sure I mean it was
clear that white was struggling but
probably I should have played it
somewhat differently there are all kinds
of ideas here I can do a cosplay night d
7 or something just for argument's sake
but i was i was being a head calculated
this up to okay too i thought okay and
usually nygean id3 there's something but
it wasn't suck wasn't so concrete okay
draw at the end thanks for watching